[Music]
how much fun was that for you to be out
there with eight other princesses Disney
Princess oh he's crazy um Moana has
always been a Disney heroine and I'm
still happy that she's actually also a
Disney princess they've been you know my
childhood heroes that's my childhood
onstage so it was great to join them
[Music]
Disney Princesses I mean come on there
were nine of you on stage at the same
time pretty crazy
I'm trying invented yeah I mean the
historical historical event this has
never happened where all of us have been
together at the same time this is a
one-of-a-kind event it's just such an
honor to be up up there with all these
amazing legends and Disney so it was
like the ultimate surprise and and
really thrilling to be out there with
all of these princesses who have had
their moment singularly but here we are
together like it's sort of amazing was
there one in particular that you were
excited to meet Mandy Moore she just
took came up to me and asked for a
selfie with me and then she texted it to
me boom got her number
I got her cell number I mean I met Jodi
Benson today Ariel like she is the sole
reason that I started singing really
managed to tell her that because I
didn't want to creep her out too much I
will I will before the day is done I'm
definitely gonna lay that on her when
you met Mandy did she tell you I don't
think she did that you actually are the
person that inspired her to start
singing that makes my selfie even more
special yeah and you've got the selfie
to recognize I mean that's really neat
that's really neat look at her no thank
you et for telling me that and welcome
that's how we're all we'd like to like
pass on and but we get information then
we passed it all this is honest news
that's what it's all about pass it on
that was great no that's very sweet if
she would have told me that it was
probably started crying so that was
sweet one princess in particular that
you like would that you met that you can
remember as a little girl watching and
then seeing you know in meeting her
today oh
anika Noni Rose Tiana
she's hard working princesses who didn't
start off that way but definitely got
their dream realm is Tiana rough night
for tips
little panic pounds it was actually
really happy to meet alii I was really
happy to meet her I just she's such a
beautiful spirit and he's just such a
kind just such a kind spirit and I was
like I would I need to beat this girl
and she's everything that she appears to
be and I'm just so proud of her
[Music]